all right let's take a look at a couple
of other things you know one of the
things I really hate is hypocritical
people and people who project who say
you're this you're this you're this when
really I'm the one who is this and there
is no greater example of this than the
rights view on speech and free speech
and we are all about being the party of
speech we saw during covid that what
they claimed to be
wanting to be the party of free speech
became something very different it
became we get to tell everyone what
content they have to allow on their
platform wait a second doesn't Twitter
then before it was owned by Elon Musk
doesn't Twitter have these uh almost
um god-like free speech rights as a
company which we shouldn't regulate to
decide what sort of content do they want
on them on their platform that's their
speech no they should be forced to allow
people to spread drinking urine cures
covet or whatever it is that they want
to spread we know that they are complete
and total Hypocrites and I have
unfortunately a downright dangerous
example of this for you today
Georgia Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker
says that he wants protesters arrested
if they're protesting after 5 PM
it's not a free speech Zone
it's a free speech time you can have the
free speech during business hours on
weekdays and if you've got to work a job
then screw you sorry you can't protest
listen to this and one thing people got
upset about me because it hurts
everybody's right to a peaceful protest
and as though during these times we have
that we can put something in in place
and I said peaceful protest let's say a
piece of protests from eight in the
morning to five in the afternoon yeah we
all have the night that means the host
loves it three problems so you need to
go home and you all get arrested that's
from then Denzel movie you either want
to go home or go to jail because it's
not peaceful anymore
by definition
it's not peaceful after 5 p.m I guess if
you have a day job sorry you can't
protest this is not free speech my
friends the government shall not and not
infringe on anyone's speech
before 5 PM and then after 5 PM
everybody's got to go home now there's
two different layers to this okay
I unders to pretend that Herschel Walker
has any idea what he's talking about for
a second
I am open to the idea
that a 3 A.M protest is far more likely
to degenerate into trouble and violence
and whatever then a 6 PM protest I'm
with you on that most municipalities
already have noise ordinances
and all sorts of other infrastructure
which apply uh rules about blocking
streets and sidewalks and all sorts of
different things okay but the idea that
eight to five is when any kind of
protest is allowed isn't supportive of
free speech isn't supportive of exactly
the values that these Republicans claim
to be supportive of now I don't really
expect Herschel Walker to know or
understand any of this as he you know
quite literally as he runs for Georgia
Senate from his house in Texas that's
his Texas house that's basically where
he lives the idea of well he Georgia
okay let's not even get into that but
the imagery is particularly stunning
here he doesn't understand anything
that's going on but it is yet another
example of how these Republicans claim
to be all about a
and sometimes they are quite literally
against a
and as is again the case
we have to take a step back and say is
this the intent of those who were the
creators of the Constitution and the
framework that we have in the United
States when it comes to not just issues
of speech but issues of freedom of and
from religion where now they say well
freedom from religion not really and by
freedom of religion really they're
talking about Christianity and oh okay
so freedom of infirm religion actually
really just means establishing
Christianity okay
you go through these one by one by one
and you start to see they don't actually
practice what they preach when the
rubber hits the road or when it comes
time to put your money whatever phrase
you want to use
it's just stuff that they say until it
becomes inconvenient that's the bottom
line